[Musique]
on se fait payer 2016 on est à paris
on se retrouve dans un temple sacré au
fin fond d'une forêt il pleut des cordes
on se les gèle
il ya des sangsues partout on est sous
la surveillance d'un guide spirituel
très respecté appeler un manque ou et on
s'apprête à faire une méditation de 27
minutes
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait là et comment
on est arrivé là
les skis et moi on se connaît depuis
neuf ans on s'est rencontré sur le
tournage d'une série télé et depuis cinq
ans on vit à des milliers de kilomètres
l'une de l'autre elles via los angeles
moi je vis à paris mais on s'appelle
quasiment tous les jours ça faisait des
années qu'on sentais impuissante face à
ce qui se passe dans le monde qu'on se
questionner sur le sens de nos vies et
sur cette société dans laquelle on ne se
retrouvait pas ont participé à un
système qu'on critiquait moi par exemple
je la première à m'infliger du sort des
travailleurs au bangladesh dans
l'industrie du textile mais je suis
aussi la première à sauter sur les
soldes appareils et moi par exemple je
lis des livres sur gandhi et sur la non
violence mais il suffisait que ma
voisine me réveille en pleine nuit pour
que ge est une seule envie c'est de
l'emploi très alors pourquoi on fait
tous des choses qui provoque des
dommages qu'ils causent de la souffrance
à des personnes qu'on connaît même pas
au monde auxquels on vit à nous mêmes et
à nos proches un jour on s'est rendu
compte que tout ce qui se passait autour
de nous et est le reflet de nos propres
souffrances
on s'est rendu compte d'une chose on
s'est demandé quelle est la cause des
guerres de la crise écologique des
violences de la domination de
l'individualisme du terrorisme du
racisme des peurs des jugements et du
manque d estime de soi pour nous toutes
les souffrances et les violences du
monde sont liés au manque d'amour
on a beau retourner le problème dans
tous les sens ça revient toujours à la
même chose ce monde a besoin d'amour
mais qu'est ce que l'amour véritablement
et en quoi ça pourrait être la solution
à tous nos problèmes de société ça fait
dix ans
je suis comédienne actrice et mannequin
alors en apparence j'ai une vie plutôt
sympathique je suis très heureuse et
j'ai la belle vie à los angeles
mais après une rupture amoureuse
dévastatrice je me suis rendu compte que
je vante je vivais dans le mensonge et
l'illusion c'est ma relation avec marine
qui m'a fait tenir le coup et nos
conversations sur l'amour et les
relations humaines
un jour j'ai une idée il ya deux ans je
me suis dit il ya qu une personne dans
le monde avec qui je pourrais faire ça
et c'est marine donc je les appelais et
je lui ai dit écoute on se plaint on
veut que ça change
franchement qu'est ce qu'on fait tu es
réalisatrice je suis actrice on n'a pas
trouvé le documentaire qu'on veut voir
va bien on coréalise ensemble bon alors
là imaginer marine à 23h30 au bout du
fil avec le décalage horaire en train de
faire pisser son chien à paris qui me
dit c'est vrai que ce moment ça m'a paru
un peu fou comme challenge
j'étais en pleine pré c en plaine
finition dans précédent documentaire
j'étais épuisé et puis je crois que j'ai
rapidement senti que ce projet n'est
plus qu'un film qu'il avait le potentiel
de bouleverser nos vies puis je connais
aussi nos deux caractères si différents
et j'avais un peu peur pour notre amitié
je me demandais si elle était assez
solide pour supporter un projet d'une
telle ampleur
alors moi j'aimerais vous dire qu'il ya
eu un événement marquant dans ma vie qui
m'a poussé à l'action
mais y en a pas eu pour moi c'est plutôt
une longue progression d'un mal être et
ne pas réussir à trouver sa place qui
m'ont fait suivre le psy comme si
l'urgence personnel étaient mélangés à
l'urgence du monde
alors quand on a décidé de se lancer y a
plus moyen de faire marche arrière
on a tout quitté ça fait deux ans qu'on
refuse du travail pour se lancer
pleinement dans ce projet même si ça
implique de gros risques financiers note
documentaire ilove darfour iam
j'aime donc je suis en français est une
recherche sur les sens de l'amour et de
son impact dans le monde on voudrait
aller chercher des inspirations dans
différentes cultures dans 20 pays sur
quatre continents
on va vivre avec des peuples indigènes
des tribus des communautés on va aussi
aller à la rencontre des experts en
sciences en biologie en psychologie en
éthologie
philosophie et des guides spirituels
notre but c'est de ramener des solutions
basées sur l'amour l'altruisme la
coopération la tolérance et la
compassion on est persuadé que l'amour
peut résoudre les crises économique
écologique idéologique et identitaire
imaginons un monde où l'amour s'impose
face à l'individualisme et la cupidité
imaginez un monde où on vivrait en
harmonie avec la nature sans la dominer
imaginons un monde où l'amour s'impose
face à la peur et au conflit imaginons
un monde où on s'accepte auraient tous
tel qu'on est
si on arrivait tout ça va être un petit
peu plus d'amour dans nos vies quelle
société se dessinerait bon alors au
début du projet évidemment il ya
quelques personnes qui nous ont dit
qu'on était utopiste mais ce qu'il faut
pas oublier c'est que l'utopie précède
toujours la réalité les plus grands
mouvements commencer par des petites
actions et des idées folles les plus
grands changements étaient initiés par
des personnes ordinaires qui savait
rêvée pour nous l'utopie c'est un moteur
certains nous ont traités aussi de
bisounours
pourtant il ya des cultures où l'amour
est proclamée est valorisé alors qu'est
ce qui fait que dans notre société
l'amour qu'ils aient le sentiment de
bâches et tous les êtres vivants soient
à ce point la dénigrer méprisé mis de
côté du coup en octobre 2015
on a lancé une campagne de crowdfunding
sur internet qui s'est emballé sur les
réseaux sociaux
à ce jour plus de 900 personnes ont
contribué financièrement pour nous aider
à démarrer le tournage on ne connaît pas
70 % des participants et les
participations viennent du monde entier
un grand mouvement de solidarité s'est
installé autour du projet est
aujourd'hui plus de centaines de
personnes nous ont proposé de l'aide en
nous offrant un logement de l'aide
financière du matériel des compétences
ou même du temps on a commencé le
tournage à bali et au népal
entouré de cinq hommes chargés de la
technique on a dû faire face à la
pression au stress la pression
financière les pannes de matériel les
accidents on a eu beaucoup de frayeurs
aussi est au bout de deux mois ont été
épuisés
et là tout ce que je ce dont j'avais
peur depuis le début est arrivé plus le
temps passait plus un fossé seraient
entre nous en clair au bout de moins
pouvait plus supporter c'est tous les
petits événements de la vie courante
additionner les uns aux autres qui nous
séparent et nous déconnecte tous on
avait fait de l'amour notre mission et
on était incapable de s'y connecter
on était pile en train de faire ce qu'on
critique et de la société l'arroseur
arrosé en essayant de discuter dans le
calme on s'est rendu compte que chacune
vivait ses expériences en fonction des
ses croyances personnelles et on
revivait des vieux schémas de l'enfance
moi par exemple quand j'étais petit
j'avais besoin de me sentir en sécurité
j'avais besoin d'être rassuré d'être vu
des temps tendu et du coup je voulais
être le centre de l'attention d'ailleurs
c'est pas par hasard si je suis devenue
actrice - al'inverse dans mon enfance
j'ai vécu nombreuses agressions à
l'école mon mode de survie était d'être
invisible ce qui fait que en fait
j'étais d'une timidité maladive et je
suis devenue réalisatrice planqué
derrière une caméra comprendre ce qui se
cachait derrière nos comportements à
bali nous a permis de changer ce que
nous ressentons aujourd'hui influencent
nos relations de demain c'est à bali au
népal qu'on a compris l'importance de la
vie en communauté de la cohésion de
groupe que ce soit dans des réunions
familiales ou des cérémonies et aussi de
la considération faite aux anciens et à
leur sagesse quand dans quand chez nous
dans notre société
les personnes âgées sont vécues comme un
fardeau au népal on est resté avec une
communauté tard où il avait ni eau ni
électricité c'était la première fois
qu'il voyait des occidentaux de leur vie
et on a été accueillis par une famille
alors un soir tous ensemble comme
d'habitude on s'est retrouvés auprès du
feu et on leur a dit qu'on vivait plus
avec nos familles il comprenait pas du
tout qu'on puisse vivre éloignés les uns
des autres
connaître la solitude courir après
l'argent pour avoir un toit négligeons
le temps passé avec nos enfants ou avec
nos proches alors pourquoi dans notre
société on fait tout pour partir le plus
tôt possible de la maison et pour être
indépendant financièrement et
émotionnellement et pourquoi le font
tout pour rester ensemble et vivre dans
la coopération et l'interdépendance à
bali
a rencontré un guide spirituel dans un
temple au milieu des rizières rapidement
à notre arrivée nous a donné le ton ne
prononcé aucun mot négatif et ben
franchement c'était pas évident en plus
ce jour là on avait quelques problèmes
techniques et c'était vraiment super
tendres aller pendant l'interview il
nous a expliqué qu'il faut constamment
être dans le respect de son
environnement de l'humain de la nature
et des animaux et seulement alors nous
vivons dans l'amour nous sommes tous
différents mais tous ensemble nous
formons un tout
nos sentiments d'aujourd'hui impactera
notre environnement de demain c'est à
bali aussi qu'on a rencontré deux jeunes
adolescentes qui nous ont impressionnés
isabelle et melatti de la green school
elle aussi était utopiste
elles se sont engagées très tôt dans
l'écologie résultat le gouverneur de
bali s'est engagée à bannir tous les
sacs plastiques de lille en 2018 en
partant et nous ont dit le changement
doit venir de nos on doit plus rien
attendre de nos gouvernements
ce que nous ressentons aujourd'hui aura
un impact sur nos actions de demain il
ya un conte amérindiens qui raconte
qu'on a tous de louhans nous qui
s'affrontent à chaque instant un qui m
est un qui souffrent celui qui survit et
celui qu'ont choisi de nourrir et ben
voilà avec notre documentaire ce qu'on
voudrait faire c'est découvrir comment
nourrir l'un plutôt que l'autre
malgré les obstacles de la vie on a
encore 18 pays à parcourir et plein de
penseurs et de faiseur a interviewé on
n'est qu'au début du film on aimerait
aussi faire une version pour les enfants
qu'on espère pouvoir diffuser dans les
écoles
si nous pouvions apprendre à aimer et à
s'aimer dès la petite enfance
si l'amour devenait une priorité et un
automatisme
nous aurions des clés extraordinaire
pour mieux vivre tous ensemble ce que
nos enfants ressentent aujourd'hui
influencera notre avenir de demain
alors voilà c'est tout ce chemin qui
nous a amené à cette méditation sous la
pluie de 27 minutes on était en plein
d'interviews avec
notre manque ou depuis une heure quand
il nous dit maintenant il est temps pour
vous de méditer sous l'arbre sacré vous
allez poser des questions à la nature et
celle qui vous répondra cinq minutes
après il pleut des cordes et donc là on
lui demande si on peut attendre la fin
de la pluie pour la méditation
normal quoi et là il nous regarde et
nous dit d'un air grave
pourquoi vous voulez contrôler la nature
la nature et tout autour de vous la
nature elle est en vous la nature c'est
vous il faut l'accepter tel quel est
alors écouter la nature et les seuls à
parler
cette méditation nous a mis face à nous
mêmes à nos limites et à notre propre
incohérences cette expérience nous a mis
face à nos façons de vivre et est
surtout à la façon dont on a de
percevoir le monde est ce qu est ce que
nos désirs et nos bonheurs éphémères
sont au prix de la souffrance d'être
sensible et de population dans le monde
nos sentiments d'aujourd'hui sont au
choix de demain pour nous l'amour est
une décision quotidienne depuis cette
méditation
on s'efforce à faire attention à ce que
chacun de nos choix soit basée sur
l'amour et c'est pour nous le seul moyen
de vraiment changer le monde
[Applaudissements]